[Musica]
benvenuti ad un nuovo episodio del
leccio con karim usa io credo di adorare
le idee
ogni volta che guardo un film telefilm
leggo un fumetto un libro gioco ad un
videogioco sono curiosissimo di sapere
cosa c'è dietro quali stato la scintilla
che ha fatto partire il progetto perché
non la maggior parte delle volte ci
soffermiamo alla realizzazione del
progetto ha come è stato fatto
il progetto ma mai alla cosa che l'ha
fatto partire quel progetto che secondo
me è infinitamente più interessante ma
proviamo a prendere il concetto di idea
ea trasformarlo in un nocciolo di un
oliva tutti i costi la tua oliva bella
da mezzo chilo quelle pugliesi belle
grosse verdi fosforescenti e poi butti
il nocciolo nel cestino dimenticandoti
che tu hai gustato un'oliva proprio
grazie al nocciolo che era la parte
centrale che ha sviluppato tutto quello
che c'era intorno
esattamente come un'idea con sto esempio
questo video è partito alla grande
ottimo però spero di avervi fatto capire
cosa intendessi io
per quanto riguarda la mia curiosità nel
cercare la benedetta idea dietro un
progetto e se tutti andassi a cercare
effettivamente immenso alle tue passioni
cosa ha spinto le persone a creare
quello che ti piace di più nella tua
vita scopriresti delle cose incredibili
prendiamo un esempio di idea che io
adoro nel mondo della musica
la canzone inside the fire dei disturbi
ed è una canzone del 2008 tratto
dall'album indestructible e questo brano
è un po particolare perché tratta il
delicatissimo argomento del suicidio
ovviamente senza neanche bisogno di
dirlo non è né la prima né tantomeno
l'ultima canzone che tratta di suicidio
ci mancherebbe e allora perché mi piace
in particolare questa l'idea che sta
dietro la canzone beh allora per
contestualizzarli meglio il cantante
david gray man quando aveva 16 anni si è
ritrovato a dover affrontare il suicidio
della sua fidanzata e io non posso
neanche lontanamente immaginare cosa
abbia passato in quel periodo e lui dopo
svariati
anni dopo aver cercato il modo più
adatto per trasportare gli ascoltatori
di quella canzone nel baratro che ha
passato lui ha trovato un'idea e in
questo caso analizzando anche il testo
l'idea è il punto di vista da cui viene
raccontata questa storia che poteva
essere il suo punto di vista e tutte le
emozioni che lui ha provato in quel
momento oppure sarebbe potuto essere il
punto di vista di lei è quello che lui
immaginava stesse passando in quel
momento ma non è così
il buon david decide di raccontare
l'accaduto
dal punto di vista del diavolo il
diavolo tentatore che aveva accanto a
lui quando è successo il fatto che gli
sussurra nell'orecchio
dammi la tua anima se vuoi rivedere la
tua ragazza vi chiedo umilmente scusa se
vi ho angosciati magari voi pensate è
uscito un video di youtube deleghe se
reader stasera invece poi mi trovate
potrai ati in posizione fetale sul
divano di casa vostra
questa serata mi dispiace però per me
questa è un'ottima idea è un'idea
curiosa e io ogni volta impazzisco nello
scoprire qual è il fulcro centrale
dietro una cosa che mi piace vi faccio
altro esempio allora nel periodo
iniziale di youtube e iniziale intendo
iniziale iniziale quindi parlo del 2006
2007 2008 proprio i primissimi anni
della piattaforma non c'era un cazzo
fondamentalmente non c'era nulla o
meglio nulla di interessante è nulla di
originale c'era tutto quello che non
potevi più trovare in televisione o
andavi ad aprire i cassettoni del mobile
di tua nonna ea cercare tra le
videocassette della tua comunione e dei
tuoi delle tue recite a scuola qualche
velo musicale che tu magari aveva
registrato su mtv o su all music
oppure lo trovavi su youtube e poi c'era
quella leggenda metropolitana che
aleggia ancora adesso di questi
fantomatici video con i gatti v che la
gente nel 2017 ancora si chiede ma ma
herat è vera questa cosa qua e c'erano
veramente così tanti video di gattini
santo padre pio se c'erano un sacco di
libri gattini mannaggia la [ __ ]
però mentre cercavo linee xi
un music video più lyrics dei coldplay
mi imbatto in un piccolo cortometraggio
chiamato rubber johnny che in realtà non
è proprio un cortometraggio è a metà tra
un video musicale di un cortometraggio
prima di spiegarvi effettivamente cosa
sia
ve le faccio vedere un pezzettino
[Musica]
con gli hobby solo il meglio
dell'allegria per tutta la famiglia
rubber johnny parla appunto di questo
ragazzo di nome giorni che un ragazzo
con delle malformazioni che è chiuso in
una stanza
guardando il video che comunque aperto
all'interpretazione quindi potrei
tranquillamente sbagliarmi e nel dire
queste cose qui comunque a quanto pare
qualcuno forse la madre o il padre lo
tiene rinchiuso lì dentro non lo vuole
far uscire e allora il regista chris
cunningham e cerca di farti capire
quanto lui vorrebbe fuggire da quella
situazione di prigionia e come te la fa
vivere questa cosa qui con lui che
magari tenta di aprire la porta o che
piange in un angolo a che ovviamente
dovranno vedere con delle immagini
psichedeliche ad altissimo voltaggio e
velocissime convinte dal sottofondo da
delle musiche anche se psichedeliche e
velocissime degli ipad sprint e da quel
che si evince lui che tenta di fuggire
appunto da questa stanza sbattendo più
volte la testa contro le pareti contro
il pavimento perché alla fine un
ragazzino ed è un ragazzino che non si è
mai potuto muovere da quando è nato e
magari non ha neanche visto nient'altro
oltre che le quattro pareti di camera
sua dove viene rinchiuso e quindi la sua
fantasia funzione in un modo diverso
rispetto a quella degli altri
l'idea centrale questo cortometraggio io
adoro e poi vuoi mettere
incubi
dai ma per essere un'idea che gli
incuriosisca non deve essere per forza
un argomento pesante come il suicidio
come il voler scappare può essere anche
una cosa molto più semplice ti può fare
coming out guglielmo per esempio sul suo
canale ha fatto una cosa immediata
diretta incredibilmente semplice ma non
banale il sushi libri il rumor era
pioggia il cazzo londra di andy quella è
una piccola piccola ma buona idea
detto questo dopo questi esempi c'è per
caso
un'idea di qualche progetto po
particolare che dopo averla scoperta mi
ha lasciato un segno indelebile nel
cervello che lo riesco più a cancellare
non riesco più a scartavetrare via e ci
devo pensare almeno una volta a
settimana a questo maledetto questa
maledetta idea
beh se vi riporto di nuovo indietro con
la memoria perdonatemi tutti i viaggi
temporali ma oggi va così grande giove e
porto indietro al periodo del del
bluetooth della scoperta del bluetooth
dei primissimi smartphone che
probabilmente non erano neanche
smartphone con cui però ci si poteva
scambiare senza fili era una roba
incredibile file in quel periodo anche a
quanto pare ci si passava gli stessi fa
il più o meno ovunque che erano 1 le
immagini di dragon ball e quelle
giravano che manco fosse in ruina e
l'altro era che veniva passato
tantissimo
un filmato che era questo lottatore di
arti marziali che si menava con una
mucca e già questo è il grottesco di
suono e siccome nel 1999 matrix ha rotto
i [ __ ] praticamente a tutti i film
nel cinema che poi da lì in poi hanno
dovuto inserire degli slow motion con
telecamera a 360 gradi in tutti i film
d'azione in questa scena c'è lui che
schiva esattamente come matrix il latte
che viene sparato dalle mammelle della
suddetta mucca
come mi chiedo io come abbiamo fatto ad
evolverci come razza umana
era una scena effettivamente divertente
poi al periodo ci sembrava tutto
incredibilmente vero come la vita vera
in realtà se la riguarda adesso la mucca
è fatta di cartoncino bristol ma che
dobbiamo fare purtroppo il tempo per
quanto riguarda gli effetti speciali è
una [ __ ] e poi grazie al passaparola
grazie a internet negli anni successivi
siamo finalmente riusciti a capire da
dove venisse quella stranissima scena ed
è tratta da cuba o so che molti di voi
stanno già ridendo a livelli e io devo a
parlare di ao tra l'altro sono convinto
che la pronuncia sia proprio cui ha un
perché
ao e il suono quando dei figli arti
marziali
la gente si colpisce in faccia gente
riderà perché questo film mi è stato
regalato
e consigliato nel periodo in cui facevo
le recensioni
talmente tanto che ho la nausea e so
anche che quando è uscito questo film
l'anno stroncato tutti è vero giuro su
dio tutti nel 2002
ecco il fatto che internet ha modificato
l'umorismo delle persone che è passato
da non fa tanto ridere a di oblio basta
avere un palo adesso è diventato un
piccolo cult e e ha un sacco di pubblico
questa parodia tra l'altro l'ha creata
una sola persona il buon steve o di iad
kirk all
non so come cazzo si pronuncia adesso lo
facciamo dire a google di utenza stava a
rompervi troppo le palle è una parodia
dei figli arti marziali bel ali e quindi
perché questa immondizia dovrebbe essere
quello che io considero una delle idee
più semplici e geniali che non ha mai
lasciato il mio cervello perché il
signor non ha fatto soltanto una parodia
di un film di arti marziali no no lui ha
letteralmente preso un film di arti
marziali vero ed esistente probabilmente
di pubblico dominio quelli che di cui
nessuno
quindi li trovi nei nei nei mercatini
dell'usato a 50 centesimi con scritto i
grandi classici delle arti marziali e ci
si è messo lui dentro il digitale per
fare delle scene diverse comiche ha
anche aggiunto scene con comparse
aggiunto scene con la buca per esempio
quella tutta in digitale
ma la maggior parte delle volte lui è
semplicemente messo dentro in green
screen nelle scene di un firmware
realmente esistente e vero di arti
marziali lui ha trovato questo film
tiger en crane fist e ci si è ficcato
dentro santi bio questa cari signori è
un'idea coi contro [ __ ] io sto per
piangere che finalmente sono riuscito a
raccontarvi di questa storia qui e sai
cosa lo voglio fare anch'io
[Musica]
salve e benvenuti in questa breve video
guida su come fare un green screen e poi
toglierlo per mettersi in un film di
arti marziali per fare un video comico
che è una cosa che la gente dovrebbe
fare almeno una volta nella vita
passo 1 prendere il vostro attore e
possibilmente 1 youtuber dal fisico
molliccio passo 2 trovare il film giusto
in questo caso cobra contro ninja questo
film e di pubblico dominio e lo si può
evincere dalla sua ripugnante copertina
perché chi ne fa non ci sbatte tanto
chissenefrega chi vuoi che li guardi
questi film
altri elementi che rappresentano il
pubblico dominio sono le terribili
immagini sul retro della copertina il
costo di un euro che non ci paghi man
con la plastica del dvd e quei cazzo di
adesivi che ti rimangono incastrati
tutti sotto le unghie passo 3 scrivere
la sceneggiatura cercate di usare tutte
le vostre doti artistiche per tirar
fuori un capolavoro anche scrivendo
lettere a caso tanto non è un vero
tutorial ragazzo e un video video comico
quindi non rompete le balle dai passo 4
il green screen settare un green screen
non è così semplice come possa sembrare
devi trovare il colore giusto che non
sia né troppo verde foglia né troppo
verde cadavere devi settare l'altezza
giusta perché un telo troppo alto
potrebbe tagliarti i piedi in un telo
troppo basso potrebbe tagliarti i la
calotta quindi cercate di regolare al
meglio tutto quello che
l'ho pagato 15 euro dai cinesi sai cosa
fatelo voi fate lavori una clip
so che molti di voi hanno un lavoro
artistico magari lavorano nel campo
della post produzione sono disegnatori
sono animatori possono di veri e propri
registi quindi sai cosa faccio per
halloween
faccio una cosa che non ho mai fatto in
descrizione potrete trovare due cose 1 e
un file che voi potete scaricare in full
hd di una mia clip in green screen
se volete voi potete scaricarla ed
usarla per creare qualcosa a tema
halloween a tema horror potete mettervi
voi un film potete fare voi lo sfondo
potete animare voi quello che volete
potete farmi morire bruciato dilaniati
in seguito dagli zombie esploso da un
elicottero potete fare quello che volete
l'importante è che questo video sia a
lungo come la clip quindi pochissimi
secondi e soprattutto niente tutto
perché non c'entrano niente con quello
che voglio farvi fare una volta che
avete fatto il mini video lo potete
inviare al secondo punto che c'è nelle
nella descrizione che è una mail fatta
apposta per ricevere questi file così me
lo potete inviare via mail caricandolo
su un mega su wetransfer su un sito di
file sharing che volete o addirittura se
avete un canale di youtube potete
caricare su youtube in modalità non
elencata e mandarmi il link scaricherò
io e poi io prenderò le migliori clip
con le migliori idee e le guarderemo
insieme nel prossimo video eh lo so
questa cosa mi si ritorcerà contro cazzo